ablehnen einstecken können nicht
vorhergesagt werden das ist ein großer
irrtum bisher gegen die wissenschaft
davon aus dass akten in bestimmten
perioden einschlagen und damit
vorhergesagt werden können bzw
wir uns zum beispiel im moment in
sicherheit leben können das ist aber
nicht der fall die erde kann jederzeit
von einem aktiven vernichtend getroffen
werden und können wir was dagegen tun
jetzt wirklich zum 26 das thema on tour
übrigens herzlich willkommen
bisher gingen wissenschaftler davon aus
dass arterien in bestimmten farben
verstärkt einschlagen und dann wieder
weniger sprich wir würden in einer phase
leben in der weniger aktiven auf der
erde niedergehen und der einstieg von
china bis 2013 sei eine ausnahme das ist
aber falsch matthias maier und sanna
holm als mark von der eth zürich und der
universität und haben diese these
widerlegt die untersuchten 22 aktiven
anschläge auf den letzten 500 millionen
jahren und kamen zu dem ernüchternden
ergebnis aktuellen einschläge wind nicht
vorher war britischer plugin geht er
davon aus dass alle 26 millionen jahre
ein absolut auf der erde einschlägt eine
käse war das ist eine art begleitstern
der sonne gebe wer dann immer einen
aktuellen regen in unserem raum bequem
im vorbeiflug verursachen würde erst in
zehn millionen jahren sollte das wieder
der fall sein bezahlen hätten wir unsere
ruhe aber weit gefehlt auf der erde gibt
es rund 190 bekannte 18 grad 22 davon
analysierten die forscher aus den
vergangenen 500 millionen jahren bei dem
der einschlag zeitraum relativ exakt
bestimmt werden kann
die forscher überprüften den zeitraum
noch mal und ordneten die einschläge
dann auf einer zeitachse 1
das ergebnis ende statt es gibt keine
häufung oder sonst irgendeine
statistische korrelation akquirieren
können jederzeit auf ihre als langes
sogar gleichzeitige einschläge die aber
von einem einzelnen aktiven stammen
dürfen wird erfolg wichtig verschwindet
die vermeintliche früher festgestellter
häufigen können also jederzeit
einschlagen würde immer deutlicher die
erde steht sogar unter einem ständigen
bombardement durch gefährliche
asteroiden der aktien von china bin
13 ist also keine seltene ausnahme und
war auch gefährlicher als ursprünglich
angenommen
der für 2013 aufgrund seines einschlag
wickelt komplett verglüht ich hätte mit
einem anderen winkel eine großstadt
komplett zerstört verglichen mit der
hiroshima bombe hatte er die 20 bis 40
tage sprengkraft ein noch größeres
exemplar 2013 sogar extrem dicht an der
erde vorbeigeflogen 2015 14 flog
unterhalb der geostationären satelliten
durch
allerdings endete update dabei seine
klug war immer mehr wissenschaftler
warnen vor dem hohen risiko einen großen
einschlags auf der erde die auch das
passiert wurde 2015 veröffentlicht 26
aktiven waren zwischen 2001 und 2010 auf
der erde eingeschlagen und lediglich ein
einschlag wurde dabei vorher gewinn alle
anderen kam im wahrsten sinne des wortes
aus heiterem himmel jedes jahr schlagen
also zwei grössere aktionäre auf der
erde ein
bisher hatten wir also so großes glück
denn die gesteinsbrocken flug mehr in
hüften oder in sonstigen unbewohnten
gebieten ein oder verdampften bereits in
der atmosphäre millionen und
abermillionen gesteinsbrocken rasen
durch unser sonnensystem und dabei sind
die zahlen allein für unseren planeten
beeindruckende vermute dass etwa eine
million aktive sich im bereich der
erdumlaufbahn befinden davon kennen wir
10.000 dass es exakt 1 prozent
inzwischen arbeiten wissenschaftler
weltweit fieberhaft daran mögliche atto
ide auf kollisionskurs mit der erde zu
finden gerade die nasa eine public
privat partnership also die
zusammenarbeit mit den privaten
unternehmen friends astronautik
bekanntgegeben zusammen mit deep space
industrie will die firma einen mini
raumschiff entwickeln das mit einem
sogenannten synthetik trackingsystem
abreden auf wird hierbei wird der
weltraum gescannt und sich schnell
bewegende objekte also abheben mit
technologien ähnlich der hdr fotografie
herausgefiltert offen wie finden wir
bald die möglichen koalitionskandidaten
und entwickelt technologien wie zu
zerstören oder von ihrer flugbahn
abzubringen
bei der immer dichteren besiedlung der
erde steigen leider auch die chancen
dass er lapidar einschlägt wo millionen
menschen getötet werden können
hoffen wir dass das nie passiert ja
klickt auf die
video wenn er mehr zum thema erfahren
wollt hier könnt ihr mir ein abo aufs
auge drücken und vergesst nicht mehr
einen auf die glocke zu geben und wenn
er jetzt kurz wartet sage ich ist dann
bleibt dran